PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to Google Maps
Developers Live.
I'm Paul Saxman.
And with me this week
is Mano Marks.
As you probably know, Google
is committed to bringing
Google Maps and Maps
applications to as many
different platforms
as possible.
So today we're really excited
to talk about the release of
the latest version of the
Google Maps SDK for iOS,
version 1.1.
We can also announce that keys
are available to everyone
through the Google
API's console.
MANO MARKS: We're going to take
a look at some of the
features of the SDK and how you
can get started with them.
We'll be demoing from
an app that actually
comes with the SDK.
So once you have the key, you
can put that in the app and
test it for yourself.
First and foremost, you see
that you get access to
Google's base map, with the same
street map data you get
on the Android and JavaScript
Maps APIs.
You also get access to our train
and satellite imagery,
the largest and most
comprehensive collection of
imagery in the world.
And we're constantly updating
and improving our data without
you having to make any updates
or changes to your
application.
There are some other interesting
features here.
For instance, you get markers
with info windows.
We're going to switch over to
the marker sample application.
Here you see the basic Google
Map with a marker on it.
You can do smooth zooming and
panning with gestures.
And because our maps on iOS are
vector based, you can also
rotate and tilt the map.
Also, you can tailor the content
of the info windows.
Now we're going to check
out the camera sample.
You can programmatically
zoom and tilt the map.
And you can see 3D buildings
come into view, nicely rising
out of the map.
Looking over at the ground
overlays demo, you can get
these ground overlays, which
are images you can place on
top of the map.
And they can be anything from
your own imagery to copies of
old maps to pictures
of flags or logos.
Here we're rotating this Google
logo to show you how to
do rotation in your app.
PAUL SAXMAN: There's a lot more
in the SDK that you get
access to, such as polylines
and traffic information.
And since it's a Google Map,
you can overlay data on it
from any of the Google Maps
web services, such as the
Places API or Directions API.
When you're ready to
check it out, visit
developers.google.com/maps,
register for an API key at the
Google API console.
And if you have any questions,
head over to Stack Overflow
for quick answers.
MANO MARKS: Thanks
for joining us.
And see you next week.